Transcription: Diana Simões
Relecteur: eric vautier
Vous est-il déjà arrivé d’avoir
un mot sur le bout de la langue ?
Vous voyez, cette sensation
un peu désagréable
où le mot est là, juste entre
vos lèvres, et il brûle.
Vous sentez presque son goût,
mais impossible de le prononcer.
Ça arrive souvent quand on est fatigué.
Les mots nous manquent ; chaque
phrase devient longue et compliquée.
Un jour, mon père a arrêté
de parler, du jour au lendemain.
C’était après un accident de vélo,
une chute et un traumatisme à la tête.
En fait, il pouvait parler, mais il avait
du mal à initier le mouvement de parole.
C’était étrange parce que, de l’extérieur,
cette difficulté ne se voyait pas.
Mais lui, il a arrêté de parler,
si bien qu’on n’a pas compris.
Puis l’hématome dans sa tête a diminué
et mon père a commencé à reparler.
Mais là, il n’arrivait juste pas
à dire les bons mots.
Du genre :
« Peux-tu aller me chercher
un yaourt dans le...
dans le... le four ? »
Il savait que les mots
qui sortaient de sa bouche
n’étaient pas ceux qu'il voulait dire.
Alors, il brodait.
Mais c’est bizarre
ce phénomène, quand même.
Non ?
En fait, parler, c’est loin
d’être une action simple.
D’ailleurs, qui s’est déjà demandé
comment ça se passe dans
notre cerveau quand on parle ?
Ça semble si simple dans notre quotidien.
Mais comment ça se passe dans notre tête ?
Il n’y a pas de consensus scientifique
quant au détail des différentes étapes,
dans notre cerveau,
lors du phénomène de parole.
Pour autant, voici
la théorie que je préfère.
C’est celle qui fonctionne le mieux
avec mes observations cliniques
que je peux faire dans
mon métier d’orthophoniste.
Le cerveau est capable de générer
une idée, de penser un concept.
C’est déjà pas mal.
De là, les connexions se succèdent
et mon cerveau va chercher
dans ma mémoire sémantique,
c’est-à-dire la mémoire qui stocke
mes connaissances du monde,
et il va sélectionner le mot désiré,
en lien avec sa signification.
Il va le chercher dans un répertoire,
le répertoire lexical des mots
que je connais et que j’ai déjà prononcés.
Dans ce processus,
à la recherche du bon mot,
mon cerveau active toutes
les images mentales du mot,
ainsi que les idées associées.
Une foule de mots viennent
alors se présenter,
mais mon cerveau, lui, il cherche l’élu.
Bon, heureusement, mon cerveau va
bloquer, inhiber toutes les idées inutiles
qui prendraient trop
de place dans ma tête.
Si je pense à une pomme
et que je cherche le mot « pomme »,
de nombreuses idées peuvent surgir :
« poire », « tarte aux pommes »,
« fruit », « croquer », « bible »,
« Adam et Ève », « serpent ».
Mais mon cerveau fait le ménage,
et il parvient à ne conserver
qu’un seul mot :
le mot.
Bon, une fois qu’il
a sélectionné le bon mot,
il active ce qu’on appelle
« les traces phonologiques ».
La phonologie est tout ce qui est lié
aux sons de la langue
et aux représentations qu’on en a.
On a tous appris à entendre, reconnaître,
prononcer, les différents
sons de la langue
lorsque nous avons appris à parler.
Ces représentations sont
stockées dans une boîte
et nous permettent de savoir
à quoi ressemblent ces sons
et comment on les réalise
sur le plan moteur :
les mouvements de la langue, de la bouche.
Si ces représentations sont altérées,
on n’est plus en mesure de se rendre
compte si l’on fait les bons sons.
On parle, on parle,
on pense dire les bons mots,
mais on utilise les mauvais sons.
Et on devient incompréhensible,
et on ne comprend pas pourquoi
les autres ne nous comprennent pas.
Non seulement il faut pouvoir
programmer les bons sons,
mais il faut pouvoir
les mettre dans le bon ordre.
Et il y a une petite
mémoire exprès pour cela.
Cette petite mémoire renferme également
tous les petits mots qui permettent
d’articuler les phrases,
des mots du genre : « mais », « où »,
« et », « donc », « or », « ni », « car ».
Mais aussi tous les autres :
« de », « par », « pour ».
Ces mots sont tout petits
et liés à la syntaxe, à la grammaire.
Leur sens n’est pas aussi fort
que le mot « chaise » ou « stylo »,
ou encore « philosophie »,
qui est un mot abstrait,
mais lié à des actions concrètes
dans notre quotidien :
des livres, des raisonnements.
Ces petits mots ont leur emplacement,
leur ancrage, dans le cerveau.
Si c’est à cet endroit
du cerveau qu’intervient la lésion,
alors la personne devient incapable
de prononcer ces petits mots
qui sont pourtant essentiels
à la construction d’une phrase.
Si cette petite mémoire est touchée,
il peut devenir également
beaucoup plus difficile
de mettre les sons dans le bon ordre
à l’intérieur d’un mot.
Pour exécuter le mouvement de parole -
le mouvement des cordes vocales,
de la langue, des lèvres -
tout un tas de signaux neurologiques
doivent être activés.
Pour ne pas se mélanger les pinceaux
et activer les signaux neurologiques
dans le bon ordre,
mon cerveau établit un plan.
C’est le schéma moteur.
Et, pendant ce temps, il doit
maintenir en mémoire les sons,
leur représentation, leur ordre.
Et ce n'est pas si facile.
Alors, heureusement,
à force d’entraînement,
mon cerveau dispose de plein de petits
schémas moteurs préenregistrés.
Pratique.
Mais il est encore possible de se louper.
Notre langue peut fourcher, par exemple.
Si tout n’est pas
impeccablement coordonné,
on peut même oublier d’ouvrir la bouche
avant de prononcer un son.
Oui, ça arrive.
Réussir à dire :
« Les chaussettes de l’archiduchesse
sont-elles sèches ou archi-sèches ? »,
c’est une sacrée petite gymnastique.
Une fois que le cerveau a établi
un plan, donc, le schéma moteur,
il est temps d’enclencher le mouvement.
Et c'est le cortex moteur
qui va s'en charger.
Il active les mouvements
du larynx et des cordes vocales,
ainsi que du souffle, des lèvres,
de la langue, des joues,
du voile du palais.
Bref, tous les mouvements du visage,
de la gorge, de la cage thoracique.
Vous ne vous en rendez pas
compte, mais, quand je parle,
mon cortex moteur envoie
constamment des ordres.
Imaginez : rien que
pour mes cordes vocales,
elles sont constamment en mouvement
sans que j’en aie conscience.
Par exemple,
pour le son « a », mettez
votre main sur votre larynx.
Allez-y !
(Rires)
Juste en dessous de votre pomme d’Adam.
Et dites, tous ensemble, le son :
« a ».
Public : A...
Eh bien, cette vibration,
ce sont vos cordes vocales
qui viennent s’entrechoquer.
Mais, à l’inverse, pour le son « p ».
Public : P, p, p.
(Rires)
Il n'y a aucune vibration.
Vos cordes vocales s'écartent.
Ce mouvement est commandé par
votre cortex moteur en permanence.
C’est fascinant, non ?
Et tout ça, c'est seulement
pour un seul mot.
Alors, imaginez toute une phrase,
qui demande parallèlement une analyse de
la syntaxe, une fluidité entre les mots.
Et puis, il faut maintenir l’idée
en mémoire tout le long de ce procédé,
ne pas se faire happer par ce qu’on voit,
par ce qu’on est en train
de faire : marcher, conduire.
Ne pas se faire envahir
par nos pensées associées.
Tout cela, c'est pour parler.
Mais, pour le chemin inverse,
comprendre ce qui nous est dit,
c’est tout aussi compliqué.
Il faut écouter les sons,
les trier, les associer.
D’ailleurs, le répertoire des mots
qui me sert à entendre
n’est pas le même que
celui qui nous sert à parler.
On le constate facilement
avec les enfants,
qui comprennent beaucoup plus
de mots qu’ils n’en disent.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Quand on converse avec quelqu’un,
en plus de la parole,
notre cerveau analyse tous les signaux,
notamment le langage non verbal.
Vous savez, les mouvements
du visage, du corps,
les émotions qui transparaissent
de façon subtile, ou non.
Notre cerveau les analyse,
il les classe et il les priorise,
tout en restant attentif à ce qui est dit.
Et, pendant ce temps, il faut
toujours maintenir en mémoire
l’idée, les sons, leur représentation.
Mon cerveau me permet d’être
adaptée à mon interlocuteur.
Il nous permet de ne pas être grossier,
de ne pas dire tout ce qui
nous passe par la tête,
de laisser l’autre parler,
de choisir un volume sonore
approprié à la situation.
La communication, ce n’est pas
que le langage verbal,
c’est tout un tas de comportements.
Mon cerveau me permet de lire
les silences, le langage codé,
tout comme il me permet de comprendre
l’implicite, l’ironie, l’humour.
En fait, mon cerveau pense
et analyse pendant que j’écoute,
il pense et analyse pendant que je parle.
Et comme si ce n’était pas assez complexe,
à cela s’ajoute la gestion des émotions :
savoir lire les émotions, les transmettre.
Ne pas se faire envahir.
Avoir la gorge serrée.
C'est dingue la complexité des mécanismes
à l'œuvre dans le langage.
Et, donc, on peut imaginer
la multitude d’attentes possibles.
Il peut y avoir des difficultés
au niveau de la mémoire sémantique,
des concepts qui seraient mal
rangés, mal connectés entre eux,
voire même absents.
Il peut y avoir des difficultés
au niveau des répertoires,
des répertoires des mots entendus
ou des mots prononcés,
des soucis avec la capacité
à agencer les sons,
à savoir à quoi ils ressemblent.
Ou encore des problèmes
dans le schéma moteur
ou même l’exécution
mécanique du mouvement.
C’est comme un petit circuit électrique
qui commanderait l’allumage d’une ampoule.
Si l’ampoule ne s’allume pas comme prévu,
il peut y avoir de multiples raisons :
les piles, l’interrupteur,
une soudure défectueuse, le fil,
la gaine du fil qui serait abîmée
et provoquerait un court-circuit.
Il suffit qu’un de ces
éléments soit touché
pour que l’ampoule
ne s’allume pas comme prévu.
Elle peut rester éteinte,
elle peut clignoter,
elle peut briller trop fortement,
trop faiblement,
elle peut grésiller.
Etc.
Elle ne s'allume pas comme prévu.
Avoir acquis le langage et le perdre
en raison d’une lésion cérébrale,
cette difficulté s’appelle : l’aphasie.
Se retrouver avec
des difficultés de langage,
c’est un petit peu comme quand
on voyage dans un pays étranger
dont on ne connaît que peu la langue.
Parler devient épuisant.
On ne comprend pas toujours
tout ce qui nous est dit.
Très vite, on éprouve une gêne sociale.
On est frustré de ne pas pouvoir aller
plus loin dans nos conversations.
On doit être concentré toute la journée.
Et, même si habituellement
on a le sens de l’humour,
on n’est pas toujours en mesure
de comprendre la blague.
On a déjà tous fait semblant de rire à une
blague qu’on n’a pas vraiment comprise.
Eh bien,
ce petit malaise qui tente de dire :
« Je ne suis pas bête.
Mais, en même temps, je n’ai pas
vraiment compris cette blague. »
(Rires)
Eh bien,
c’est ce que les personnes
aphasiques vivent au quotidien,
mais pour des propos tout simples,
avec leurs proches,
dans leur propre maison,
et sans échappatoire.
Mon travail, c’est
la rééducation de l’aphasie.
Il est possible de perdre
le langage de multiples manières :
AVC, trauma crânien,
tumeur cérébrale, démence.
Le cerveau est tellement complexe
qu’il y a autant d’aphasies que de cas
selon l’endroit où la lésion se trouve.
Mais, si on s’arrête
à ce qui est manifeste,
à ce que l’on voit,
on a vite fait de penser qu’une personne
aphasique est folle ou bête.
Et pourtant ça n'a rien à voir.
Mon père a bien récupéré de son aphasie.
Enfin, d’extérieur, parce que, lorsqu’une
personne aphasique a une lésion cérébrale,
il n’est pas possible
de récupérer totalement.
Mais, parce que mon cerveau
est une machine extraordinaire,
il est possible de récupérer en partie,
amoindrir la fatigue, compenser.
Parfois, le trouble est léger, mais
la nervosité et la fatigue occasionnées,
même si elles sont invisibles,
sont, elles, bien présentes.
L’invisibilité de ce handicap
est une double peine,
parce que socialement on se sent jugé,
sujet à de multiples
interprétations sur nous
et on a peur du regard de l’autre.
Quand on est une personne aphasique,
il faut réussir à faire le deuil
d’une image sociale qu’on a renvoyée
pendant des années.
Une image qu’on a construite
sous le regard de l’autre
et par son regard.
Ce deuil peut être très douloureux,
notamment auprès des proches,
parce que le langage
nous permet de penser,
il nous permet d’être qui on est.
C’est pourquoi il est
si important de comprendre
la complexité de ce qui est en jeu,
parce que nous pourrions tous être
amenés à vivre cela à travers un proche,
ou en étant simplement une rencontre
pour une personne aphasique.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)